comment financer sa création
d'entreprise pour y répondre jeudi 24
mars les porteurs de projets avaient
rendez-vous à l'université de versailles
saint quentin pour l'événement phare en
mass start up organisé par startin'
saclay et financé technologie cette date
était adressé en particulier aux jeunes
entrepreneurs
le problème de du jeune qui va se lancer
c'est qu'il n'est pas forcément bien
informée donc l'idée c'est justement dû
fournir cette information supplémentaire
pour l'accompagner dans sa démarche de
création kiss kiss bang bang ou encore
la banque publique d'investissement une
dizaine de financeurs ont exposé leurs
propositions ou différentes start up du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et du plateau de saclay c'est partie de
notre rôle aussi d'accompagner les
créateurs d'entreprises et de les aider
dans leurs projets et de les renseigner
sur tout sur ce qu'il est ce qu'il est
possible d'avoir en termes de l'entente
de financement à leur stade alors sam
d'avancé je suis porteur de projet d'une
petite start up qui s'intéressent à la
clarification orval en africain je suis
venu me renseigner sur comment comment
se financer comme en récupérer un peu
d'argent et puis aussi à développer un
peu le réseau rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes
moi j'ai lancé avec deux associés une
start up qui s'appelle work is wrkz est
on
démythifier la force commerciale des
entreprises grâce à des étudiants qui
sont auto-entrepreneurs je suis venu ici
aujourd'hui pour rencontrer du monde
pourrait changer surtout une vingtaine
de start up étaient présentes pour ce
moment des changes après la question du
financement se pose la question du
développement de l'entreprise
quelles structures peuvent les
accompagner pour concrétiser leur projet
des réponses seront apportées le 31 mars
à orsay dans le cadre de l'événement
foster mass start up